-It is Tuesday.
And it is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Now welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
Now, I'm gonna show you
five different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
or not you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
I can see the confusion
right there.
Yeah.
Just grab whatever.
The first one to grab it,
that's yours.
You own it now.
Now, you can vote for
all of them, you can vote
for none of them.
Whatever you want.
As long as you have fun.
And we're gonna
see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
do you guys have your clickers?
-Got it.
Hope I don't get shocked.
-All right.
Good, good.
Whichever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
on the show so that you can
all like it and wetweet it.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah!
-It's a shared experience.
Okay. Are you guys ready?
The first one here --
this one I think is going to --
-You like this one?
-I think this one's gonna be
the winner.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Tepid response.
-Yeah.
-Tepid response.
I still -- I still have faith.
Everyone -- I think this is
not gonna work at all.
-You think it's gonna be 101?
-Yeah, we're good.
I think we're good.
Everyone made their choices.
The camera cut to everyone,
and their hands were silent.
They were sitting there like...
[ Laughter ]
They made
their decision immediately.
They are not on board.
-Right in the middle of that,
they made it.
-I think the audience
does not enjoy this.
Let's see the results live
on this one.
What is it?
Yes or no?
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh!
-All right, not bad.
That's pretty good.
-Not bad.
-That's about the reaction.
That's about the reaction.
-Yeah. Tepid.
-Yeah, tepid.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What is it?
A clam?
-No. What is it?
-A mussel? What --
Does it grow
on the side of boats?
All right.
Cast your votes.
I think this one's gonna
do pretty well.
Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa!
-What is it?
-164!
-I don't know what it is.
Let's be real.
Okay, how about this next one?
It's gonna be good.
Here we go. This one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
That's pretty good.
People are discussing.
You can like them all,
if you like.
You can like them all.
You can dislike them all.
I'm liking that one, as well.
-I like that one.
-I like that one, too.
Let's see the results
on that one.
Oh!
-So far. No?
I like it.
This one's fun.
This one's real.
I like this one
because it's real, and it's fun.
-Real fun?
-Yeah, here we go.
This one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Oww!
-Oww!
Oww! Wolfman Snacks!
-All right.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Oh!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's good and it's fun.
It's real.
That's a party right there.
That's a party, man.
We have the last one here.
-Oh, what?
-The last one, yeah.
Don't put away your clickers
just yet.
-I threw mine away.
-This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Come on!
-You can vote for it,
you can not vote for it.
No?
I see a lot of head shaking,
but you're laughing at it.
This is
a very difficult decision.
They're all winners.
We're all winners
here at "The Tonight Show."
That's our slogan.
Let's see the results
on this one.
No!
♪♪
The winner is --
The winner is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
I'll post this
during the commercial break.
It you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet and enjoy!